hey guys it is the 25th of july today my
name is jeff mcdonald and i'm here to
get you covered up on the very best
things that happened in gaming just week
let's go
first up by waves David data has talked
about the romances in dragon ages past
and future he said that since dragon age
2 only had 40 mountable characters they
were all made bisexual to keep the
players options open comparatively for
Dragon Age Inquisition Gaeta has said
we're going to have straight romances
alongside by social romances alongside
Gabe romances I thought that was pretty
important because those are different
stories to tell next up battlefield
hardline has been delayed until early
2015 series created dice have said the
game needs more fine-tuning time to
incorporate fan suggestions into the
multiplayer and to flush out the story
of the single-player the june beta has
apparently spurred the devs into
elaborating on what will make the game
better even though it has meant that the
game stuff is a delay dice have also
said they don't want a repeat of the
extremely unstable battlefield 4 launch
which generated loads of hate the
shooter early on while we're on the
subject dragon age inquisition also
gathered itself yet another delay the
RPG has been pushed back a month to the
18th of November but given the game was
originally going to come out in the fall
of 2013 chances are fans anticipating
the game's release are used to waiting
by now the plan is to use the extra time
to make the heroes choices impactful and
ensure the open spaces of the game are
engaging
developer ready at dawn who are
currently hard at work on the order 1886
have said they needed to have their game
on the ps4 to facilitate the visual
quality that they were after community
manager Jay Goldberg has said that any
other console would not work
particularly since the studio used full
performance capture for all characters
in the game they're also utilizing the
same character models for gameplay
sequences and cutscenes to smooth the
transition as Goldberg explains we're
moving the camera in the space we're not
loading a video he went on to say that
he hasn't seen a game set in this area
yet and he thinks gamers will be on
board with all the politics inventions
and whatnot from the period the internet
has been pretty troubled this week as
Google's attempts to eventually buy out
our very Souls seem to be moving forward
with their 1 billion dollar acquisition
of twitch unless you're among the dozen
or so people who is cool with Google
earning everything you'll probably be on
board with those that question the
company earnings so much of the video
streaming internet since they already
handily got their claws into YouTube
GamesBeat has reported that the deal is
going through although there's not been
an official announcement or confirmation
from either twitch or our future
overlords Google kill a damn fine search
engine though as for your question of
the day let me know down in the comments
if you think Google's acquisition of
twitch is a disaster or if you're okay
with the move and why this week on
flight cam explains the nitty-gritty of
pc graphics for you but just takes a
look at some phenomenal game remix and
you can check out all our coverage of
comic-con which is happening right now
on games but those are all the good
things I wanted to tell you about this
week thanks for joining me yet again and
be sure to have yourself a lovely
weekend
you